[Music]
all right
welcome back as we continue live we are
on beautiful West Palm Beach Florida now
to another critical race right here in
the Sunshine State Senator Marco Rubio
has opened up a commanding double-digit
lead over Democrat Val demings after
this strong debate performance let's
take a look
the extremists on abortion in this
campaign is congresswoman demings she
supports no restrictions no limitations
of any kind she voted against the former
she's against the four-month man she
voted against a five-month ban she
supports
taxpayer-funded abortion on demand for
any reason at any time up until the
moment of birth because you didn't
support a 20-week ban you didn't support
to the time but when is that that's the
vague language they all give and then
they talk about the doctor and the
family let me tell you who else is in
that room in that abortion room the
government is in that room because she
brought them in there she wants the
taxpayer to pay for that abortion that's
government involvement not just to pay
for that but to pay for them all over
the world look the senator can play
um
National Security expert all he wants I
know he needs that for his next
Presidential run congresswoman I need to
stop you there and I want to give
because he mentioned the senator another
30 seconds of the senator yeah I mean I
don't know what she means by play
National Security yes but I'm the vice
chairman of the intelligence committee
and was the previous chairman of it so
it's actually my job but my opponent has
been in Congress now for half a decade
and has never passed a single piece of
legislation into law not one the only
thing she does is vote 100 with Pelosi
now Senator Rubio's right Val demmings
says nothing but a rubber stamp for
Nancy Pelosi by the way a 100 percent
Joe Biden voter 100 of the time uh now
wants to be a rubber stamp for Chuck
Schumer now she already supports the
Biden agenda 100 of the time like Joe
Biden uh she doesn't have fond feelings
about half the country she even
campaigned with a far left activist who
actually compared Republican voters to
the Taliban and Al Qaeda now deming's
also he preys on the teachers union boss
who tirelessly worked to keep your kids
out of school she called her quote the
amazing Randy Weingarten you know the
the teachers union had
she also prays left's very thoughtful
plan to dismantle and defund the police
that's a genius move and like every
other radical Democrat she also supports
open borders wants to limit the domestic
production of oil and gas the lightblood
of our economy through the Socialist new
green deal and during her five years in
Congress only two of her sponsored Bills
ever became law and both renamed Post
Office Buildings now in contrast
just the record anyway in contrast Marco
Rubio is one of the most productive
thoughtful freedom-loving members of the
United States Senate let's give a warm
Florida Welcome to Senator Marco Rubio
foreign
[Applause]
is preparing for debate maybe any other
candidates I pray that they watch that
debate with you and Val demings uh
that's my job that's what I do
um I thought that was a really good
powerful moment for you and the whole
debate I thought she did very poorly
you're both up by double digits you're
both running against candidates that are
a hundred percent in support of Joe
Biden's policies I don't think there is
a bigger Choice election in our lifetime
senator
well first of all we're not by anything
because we have the votes haven't been
counted so it's important everybody get
out and we vote and we run through the
tape but that's what they want us to do
but I I and
um
I don't know what Charlie Chris is not
because he's he's the only one in
Florida we were just talking about this
a moment ago he will have lost to me in
2010 and then uh Rick Scott in 2014 and
now at Iran to Santa's it's a Rite of
Passage
that's like the trifecta
and uh but um he's also the only
candidate I know that had those three
three people were introduced on the
stage Charlie Crist Ron DeSantis and his
fan Ron and and Charlie Chris fan got
his own introduction as well so um that
the guy's not a serious candidate but I
don't know how you can be with Nancy
Pelosi 100 of the time like Val demmings
is Pelosi isn't even with Pelosi 100 of
the time so uh it's a tough thing to do
so um anyway and by the way I don't
think Joe Knows today's Thursday
um
ouch that was mean right
they're not responsible for what I say
you know Senator I look at what's
happened to the country and I was asking
the governor about this the last 20
months I my son is here with me tonight
he's 24 years old he lives in Florida
and I worry about his future I worry
about my daughter's future she's 21. I
worry about everyone in this room their
family their children and
grandchildren's future I've never seen
things get this bad this fast to me this
is a very this is an inflection point
for the country am I overstating it no I
think here's what we need to understand
the same party that has that's a
Democratic party that I don't say this
with any pleasure that's controlled by
two groups these laptop liberals and
these Marxist Misfits that's the core of
the democratic party today not the
voters not Democratic voters but the
leadership of that party that's what
they take their orders from and I'll be
very blunt if these people stay in power
for another two years they'll destroy
the country if they get their hands on
this state or any they'll destroy the
state and so to me this choice and I'm
glad the governor is here tonight you
know I always say this to people people
all want to come to America America all
these guys like to talk about how
terrible America is but everybody wants
to come here and and then the same
people say oh and by the way Florida is
a terrible place but they all want to
move here so
um by the way the greatest moment in
covid were all these Democratic
Governors and politicians that supported
shutdowns in their states they come
visit you down here and they all got
caught the cottage industry I mean if I
had a dime for every one of the
lockdowners who came left lockdowns to
come to Florida I'd be a very wealthy
man I mean this happened over and over
again it did and they got caught almost
every time that's the thing though when
your biggest critics people can posture
and they can emote politically and say
this stuff but how do they behave and if
even your worst critics are coming to
your state then you know you must have
been doing something right I don't know
what my favorite was either was either
Gretchen Whitmer who came and then lied
about coming or AOC that came down and
was partying without a mask on
oh I see
I see we have a lot of AOC fan in the
crowd
but my favorite moment is when you talk
to one of these Democratic politicians
and invariably it comes down to oh so
I've been down to Florida a bunch oh
yeah why he goes my mom lives in Boca so
that's a great line you know let me look
at the other side of this everyone's
talking about a wave election Senator
you said something I hope everybody
heard loud and clear
there are a lot of polls but there's
only one poll that matters and that's on
Election Day when we count now many of
you can vote early in Florida you've
perfected the system down here
thankfully it's no longer 2000 or 2016.
um but it's so critical because if let's
say the Democrats took over the Senate
and they had a majority
I don't think you disagree with me
they'd eliminate the legislative
filibuster they'd pack the courts they'd
make D.C Puerto Rico statehood done deal
because they think that would guarantee
them four Senate seats in perpetuity
um they would do and they would continue
down this path of new green deal
radicalism and I if that happened I
don't know if we'd ever dig ourselves
out of it no they would also take over
our election system they pretty much
said they want to do that
um Val Deming says she also wants the
federal government to potentially take
over our property insurance which is uh
he can just imagine maybe that's what
the 87 000 IRS agents will do is run the
insurance company but but I mean you the
list goes on of the parade of horribles
of things they would do look if they
were in power I'm convinced of this now
if they had a filibuster no filibuster
whatever and they had been in charge
during the covid they would have locked
down the country they would have done to
the country what they did to New York
what they did to California what they
did to Illinois that's what they would
have done in fact Val demons has said as
much and I think both demings and Chris
are on record as as late as I think last
summer asking for another shutdown in
this state they would have spent four
something trillion dollars uh they they
tried to and uh and even in their
infrastructure bill they brag about a
court only a quarter of that money went
to infrastructure the rest of it went to
take on very serious problems like you
know racist roads and discriminatory
trees and whatever else they can think
of and so look I'm sorry I hate to say
this about my fellow Americans these
people are out of their minds and they
cannot be allowed to be near power you
know it raises
the bottom line new Cambridge defines it
really well
um the night he became speaker that
Republicans were out of power 40 years I
was the emcee of that event I was a
local radio host in Georgia at the time
how do you reconcile capitalism versus
socialism how do you reconcile defun
Nobel versus Law and Order how do you
reconcile energy domestic energy
production and energy dependence how do
you reconcile
capitalism socialism put all these
issues together they're very different
competing visions
to me the only answer is one side's
going to win and it better be our side
is I don't see any Middle Ground here
yeah I mean you know just look at how
these states have performed like since
I've been Governor you have States like
California and New York people are
fleeing those States they're not safe
they tax lockdown all those other
they're not given to Gavin Newsom enough
credit he's the first governor in the
history of California that had a net
Exodus of it out of his State not a net
increase but you see though that the
different the Florida blueprint has
worked I mean people just by bringing
their wealth or their their visitation
moving here but what they want to do is
take those failed Blue State models and
they want to force that over the entire
country so they want to do things like
Marco mentioned the elections they want
to Outlaw voter ID in every election in
our country can you imagine what
happened they want to mandate
in Florida since I've been Governor we
banned ballot harvesting in Florida but
they
they would federalize it and they would
require ballot harvesting and so I agree
with Marco in the sense of it's not just
maybe we disagree on taxes maybe we
disagree on welfare spending these
differences are fundamental it's about
really what it means to be an American
and what are our foundational principles
and the left wing of our country has
departed from the the principles that
have made the country great they're not
there you can't reconcile these two
versions one side has to win in the
future there was a time you know
Democrats are a little left Republicans
are to the right but we both operated
like in the same universe now what's
happened here is that these people they
live in these little bubbles like the
laptop liberals they live in these
little bubbles the Marxist Misfits
there's no hope for but the laptop
liberals they live in these little
bubbles where they have a lot of power
and everyone they know is just like them
and so they have these ideas and they're
immune from the consequences okay since
Joe Biden has been president 4.4 almost
4.5 million people have entered this
country illegally okay the governor flew
48 of them one day to make a point to
Martha's Vineyard
48. they
they arrive they arrive the state of
Massachusetts immediately declares a
state of emergency 48 people
they mobilize a hundred and something
National Guard troops two to one ratio
then they do what all these laptop
liberals do they stage the sting at a
church where they show look we're
feeding them we're giving them toys and
then they deport them to Cape Cod 24
hours later when no one was looking less
than 24 hours they live immune from
there because it's not their schools
it's not their hospitals it's not their
cities that are that are being
overcrowded and you know where they're
moving to they're moving to Immigrant
communities and Hispanic communities and
States like Florida and Texas and
Arizona who have to share all the burden
because these laptop liberals they live
immune from the consequences of their
craziness and that's why they're that
I'll tell you what one of the areas that
you're uniquely qualified to talk about
is the area of National Security I am
very concerned I don't think Joe Biden
Garners any respect for moral leaders
hostile regimes like Vladimir Putin and
Russia president XI in China the mothers
in Iran the Saudis mocked him made fun
of him denied his request to increase
oil production as a matter of fact
reduced it and then exposed that he
wanted to collude with them to delay the
announcement of their reduction in the
production of oil uh by the way if any
if it was a republican they'd be put in
jail they'd be investigated probably
impeached well as you know I'm worried
about the National Security side of all
this because we see what's happening in
Ukraine and I believe President Chi when
he says that he wants to quote reunify
with Taiwan it's not reunify he wants to
take over Taiwan well to be fair to
Biden okay as we all know Saudi oil is
cleaner for the environment than
American oil is right so you know my my
headline tomorrow Marco Rubio says Saudi
oil is cleaner so oh
according to Biden so my solution is
just to pump American Oil put a sticker
that says Saudi and confuse him and
maybe he'll be for it so but but going
back to the point that you're making
yeah so let me give you one example okay
we have and I love our military but as
civilian leadership and so you look at
it's embarrassing you look at their
Twitter page and they've like video
after video about the proper use of
pronouns no you need to be focused on
how do we blow up Chinese aircraft
carriers if they ever attack us so of
course they don't respect the guy they
don't respect him and and why would they
and so I think they view them as
incompetent and then I think you see
okay if you're bad to America and mean
to Biden he'll be trying to be nice to
you you're Iran he'll want to do a deal
you're Venezuela he'll want to do a deal
but China you know John Kerry who's
still around he's like the Charlie Chris
to the federal level he um he's still
around and and he wants to do this
climate deal we're going to take this
show on the road
thank you
and so you know China's sitting there
saying we're going to take these guys to
the cleaner you know we're going to take
these guys and that's what they're doing
so you're absolutely right it's
dangerous yeah it's Reckless and the
China threat is the threat of the 21st
century either they will be the world's
most powerful country or we will and I
promise you a world where China is the
most powerful country in the world is
not a good world it is not the one I
want to leave my kids
I hope everybody's listening because
that is a real clear present danger for
the country hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else